we have an absolutely huge bit of news
and a major step forward
in the criminal investigation of donald
trump his associates
and his organization uh and i am going
to go back to what is sometimes called
the boiling frog
situation because it really applies here
in terms of the normalization of what's
going on
yesterday we learned that the manhattan
district attorney cyrus vance jr
has convened a grand jury to decide
whether to indict former president
donald trump
or his associates or other elements of
the trump organization
this means that the district attorney at
least believes
that he has evidence of possible crimes
otherwise you don't convene a grand jury
whether the crime was committed by trump
himself
or someone close to trump or all of the
above we don't yet know and that is
exactly what the grand jury
will determine the washington post
reports that the panel was convened
recently and will sit three days a week
for six months this is not super
surprising
in terms of the duration white collar
crimes take a lot of grand jury time
the cases are complicated and
typically grand juries look at more than
one matter so it probably isn't
all trump all the time for the period
that they will be on the grand jury
now as you might remember manhattan
district attorney cyrus vance has been
investigating donald trump's
pre-presidency business dealings for
more than two years now and part of that
was slowed down
because while donald trump was president
he was able to regularly obstruct
vance obtaining his tax records that
stopped when trump left office
and those records uh were directed to be
provided
to cyrus vance uh relatively recently
and
this is an important detail this
investigation relates to things trump
and his company did before trump was
president and not
during now vance's office said in court
filings
that it was investigating quote possibly
extensive and protracted
criminal conduct at the trump
organization this includes tax fraud
insurance fraud falsification of
business records and a whole bunch of
other stuff
now before looking at the details a
grand jury looking at a former president
is a huge deal it's enormous
uh and we have to understand that we're
gonna
look at some things that former
prosecutor renato marriotti said and
we're going to talk about you know is
trump likely to ever go to prison the
answer is no
but consider the sort of you know the
you
the boiling frog in the skillet you
slowly turn up the temperature
it doesn't notice that it's getting
burned consider how far we've come
where as asha rangapa said on twitter
before the presidency the access
hollywood grab him by the you know what
tape oh my goodness this is crazy this
is the craziest thing we've ever seen
we have a grand jury now considering
indictments of a former president
and it didn't even make that big of news
like it made news but it wasn't
that big so think about the degree to
which things have
slid over the last many years now former
federal prosecutor renato marriotti
who has been a guest on this show had a
good twitter thread about the meaning of
all of this and just a few points
that renato makes one quote the mere
fact that a special grand jury was
impaneled
does not mean that any particular person
will be charged it does not necessarily
mean that trump himself will be charged
but it is fair to say
that vance's investigation is far along
and that
charges are on the horizon does not mean
it will be against trump
number two when it comes to trump
himself in cases like this
it's often about what you can prove
trump knew
when you're talking about this type of
fraud in white-collar crime and renato
tweets quote
whenever i investigated tax or fraud
cases the case came down to whether we
had sufficient proof of the defendant's
knowledge of the false statements
contained in the documents
that state of mind is what distinguishes
fraud from a mere mistake a slip up is
not fraud
very similar to perjury people say
things that are not true while under
oath in court all the time
but why don't we often see perjury
charges because you have to
prove they didn't just make a mistake it
wasn't just a misrecollection that they
were really lying and state of mind is a
big part of that
uh and lastly um renato tweets quote
fraud is just when you lie to people to
get their money
so the case usually comes down to
whether the defendant
knew the statements in the documents
were false it's easier to prove
knowledge for people involved in
preparing or authorizing the documents
like weisselberg weisselberg was one of
the top
uh trump organization people and then in
terms of expectations and this matches
what i've been saying for some time
renato tweets quote don't be surprised
if people like weisselberg are their
initial target
to induce him or others to flip someone
like trump or his children will only
have liability
if they knew of the false statements and
participated in the scheme
in some way or moved it forward somehow
so this doesn't change any of the things
we've said
trump maybe would be charged no way that
this leads to trump going to prison
but but but if trump were a normal
person
i would probably be saying this guy's
going to prison they've got this guy
and what i mean by that is think back to
the michael cohen
indictment and and conviction michael
cohen
names trump in the case in which
michael cohen went to prison for his
crimes that's trump's personal lawyer
that would normally be a major sign that
trump is guilty of something
but this is a rich former president and
we have a two-tiered justice system in
the united states and these
at their core are crimes for which you
really need to prove state of mind so
this may go on for a long time
it will certainly trigger trump i don't
think trump ends up in prison but let's
talk about the reaction
from the former president next donald
trump has absolutely
lost it on his new blog
over the news that a grand jury has been
convened in manhattan to evaluate
evidence that donald trump and or his
associates and or his organization
have committed crimes as a reminder we
already outlined that the washington
post reports
a grand jury panel has been convened and
it will sit three days a week for six
months they will be looking at all sorts
of different
possible crimes that trump associates
and his organization
may have committed donald trump reacting
immediately triggered which is exactly
what we've predicted for a long time
which is if these criminal probes get
going once trump is out of office
trump is going to lose his mind and he's
already losing his mind and nothing has
even happened yet let's review his blog
post where donald trump opens by saying
this is a continuation of the greatest
witch hunt in american history
it began the day i came down the
escalator in trump tower and it's never
stopped
they wasted two years and 48 million in
taxpayer dollars on mueller and russia
russia russia now remember the mueller
probe
recovered more money than it cost trump
goes on to say impeachment hoax number
one
impeachment hoax number two and it
continues to this day with illegally
leaked confidential information
no other president in history has had to
put up with what i have had to
and on top of all that i have done a
great job for our country
whether it's taxes regulations or
military veterans space force our border
speedy creation of a great vaccine said
to be a miracle
and protecting the second amendment we
could do an hour debunking each of those
this is purely political and an affront
to the almost 75 million voters who
supported me
in the presidential election and it's
being driven by a har
by highly partisan democrat prosecutors
new york city and state are suffering
the highest crime rates in history
that's not true
and instead of going after murderers
drug dealers human traffickers and
others they come after donald trump
interesting that today a poll came out
indicating i'm far
in the lead for the republican
presidential primary
and the general election in 2024 that's
not true not that second part
and lastly trump says our country is
broken
our elections are rigged corrupt and
stolen
not true our prosecutors are politicized
and i will just have to keep on fighting
like i have been for the last five years
trump off the rails and just imagine
if there are charges just imagine if
there are charges what will happen with
this man's
psyche donald trump jr getting in on the
action retweeting someone named mike
davis
who said quote since 1923 the trump
family
has built a worldwide real estate and
hospitality empire
now highly partisan democrat prosecutors
are on a witch hunt
to find paperwork crimes crimes and
quotes
and they ignore clear evidence of
foreign corruption
and other real crimes by the biden crime
family folks it is conspiracies all the
way down
you know the phrase it's turtles all the
way down it is conspiracies
just all the way down and this is going
to be a very interesting six months
the timeline that is mentioned would be
in if there will be indictments around
the end of summer
and then starting to get into court
and seeing what direction these
indictments will go
in the fall so between now and november
potentially just a a a series
of never-ending um insanity
is what we are expecting to see here um
we have on monday memorial day an
incredible
one-day david pakman show membership
special
we have had a lot of membership
attrition due to the continued
financial strain that many people are
under that's sad and i understand that
hundreds of members canceling over the
last couple of months
we are trying to do something to turn
that around
and that is that monday memorial day
we're doing a single day membership
special i would love for you to
participate
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com and then monday morning
you'll hear all about it alright quick
break
let me know on twitter what do you
expect to come of this grand jury you
can find me on twitter at deepakman
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
let us not forget that you can at any
time of day
if at 3 50 in the morning you get a
hankering for a david pakman show
membership and a david pakman bonus show
it requires merely going to join
pakman.com and signing up
for someone of average computer
proficiency this process takes under a
minute
okay get access to that bonus show by
signing up at joinpakman.com
let's do some good news today we are
really starting to crush the coronavirus
my friends we are really doing it check
out some of these beautiful numbers now
this doesn't mean it's over
people are still suffering people are
still dying but we are seeing numbers go
very much in the correct direction
coronavirus cases
in the united states which peaked in
mid-january at
255 000 cases per day
are now down to 25 000 cases per day
that's a decline
of more than 90 percent in new
daily cases coronavirus
deaths which peaked in late january
at more than 3 400 a day
9 11 plus 10
every day that's where we were in late
january
those are now down below 550 a day the
lowest numbers
going all the way back to july of 2020.
still too many
but importantly once we get down to
about
300 a day you're really talking about
something that has gotten below the
level of your typical
flu season we're not there yet but we
are going in that direction
now in the more heavily vaccinated
states the numbers
of coveted deaths are already down to
roughly the average flu deaths in a
normal flu season as an example in the
state
or commonwealth of massachusetts on many
recent days
they are seeing seven coveted deaths
five cova deaths zero one day two
another twelve another
in a normal flu season you see four to
five flu deaths
a day in massachusetts we are getting
down to that level in some states this
does not mean it's over
but it does mean that at the current
level of vaccination
we're getting very close to crushing it
completely now as a reminder
while we are seeing this level of case
decline
while only having 39 of the u.s
population totally vaccinated
we are going to see a much more uh
significant decline
as we get to 50 and beyond percent of
vaccinated people
cases have already dropped 90 percent we
are only 39
fully vaccinated in the united states
when we get to
50 vaccination these numbers will be
even lower i think we will have no
trouble getting to 50. i think we'll
have
not much trouble getting to 60 once we
get beyond 60
it's going to depend on how much
anti-vaccine sentiment
we can do away with because that will be
a problem there is going to be this
limit
roughly uh 20-ish percent of the country
doesn't want the vaccine
and you have to assume that on top of
that there are people who sort of like
casually want it but they won't go and
actually get it
um so that is going to be a challenge
once we get beyond 60
but by the 4th of july things are going
to be looking
really really good now as a reminder my
prediction was under 20 000 cases a day
by memorial day
were five days away i think it's gonna
be close i think we're going to be right
there we we essentially we're at 25k
a day right now and we have five days to
go so we need to
shed a thousand cases a day
between now and memorial day uh lastly
of course
this is a global pandemic and it's a
global effort
i'm glad to finally be able to say the
global cases and deaths
are continuing down from the global peak
of about
eight hundred and thirty thousand cases
per day in early april
we are now down to about five hundred
and eighty thousand cases per day
globally still a crazy number
but a decline of about 30 percent
in global cases global deaths
down about 17 from their peak
still lagging no doubt a lot of people
are dying
but you'd rather be at this number and
heading down
than at this number and heading up so
let's
keep things going let's keep getting
ourselves vaccinated we are really
seeing the light at the end of the
tunnel
we had a great conversation yesterday
with infectious disease dr isaac bogash
he was optimistic check that out if you
missed yesterday's podcast and we are
going to have to now
uh start i mean listen i know i say say
this
we are the envy of the world in terms of
vaccine availability
there are countries desperate for
vaccines they get a hundred thousand
and they are thrilled and we have
millions and millions we've we've
already done hundreds of millions of
doses
they're available just walk in all it's
hard it's hard not to get a vaccine at
this point you can get them so many
places
um and still so many people they're just
not doing it let's do that we
we're going in the right direction let's
do it however
there are still deaths despite what
lauren beaubert recently claimed let's
talk about that next
this is just so weird ridiculous
radical rancid and regressive republican
congresswoman lauren bober
falsely claimed the other day that the
state of texas
hasn't recorded even one covet death
in more than two months what the hell is
she talking about speaking to right-wing
commentator gina
louden on dr gina prime time
uh bober ridiculed the house mandate for
mask wearing
said she enjoys telling speaker nancy
pelosi
to kiss her mask clever right
maybe english comprehension is suffering
on my end maybe this is not actually
what lauren beaubert is saying but i've
watched this three times now
it really sounds like lauren beaubert is
saying
nobody in texas has died of covid since
march 2nd when they pulled
the mask mandate also by the way pay
attention to her
defiant and principled opposition to
everything that public health experts
are proposing
but listen carefully here uh i think
she's saying
nobody in texas died of covet since
march 2nd take a look
you know i'm really enjoying uh telling
speaker pelosi to kiss my mask though
uh yesterday thomas massey madison
cawthorne
cothorn
brian mast beth van dyne and several
other colleagues join me in refusing to
wear
a mask on the house floor thomas massey
and i both got warnings
and both of our letters ended up in the
same exact place ironically the trash
leftists won't even listen to the
bureaucratic
the bureaucrats at the cdc and it just
goes to show
that this party's follow the science
slogan
is a total joke just like this entire
administration just like the entire
democrat party
they want to tell you to listen to
science and listen to data and facts but
they haven't done that for more than a
year
two weeks to slow the spread turned into
communism really really quickly now it's
show me your papers but don't forget
gina
texas removed their mask mandate two
months ago and sleepy joe called it
neanderthal
thinking no sir republicans are just
following the science and since removing
the mass mandate
two months ago texas has not reported a
single
covet death not one she said it
she is saying that in texas there has
not been
a single coveted death since they pulled
their mask mandate
now unfortunately the truth is 3 600
texans have died of covid
since march 2nd march 2nd is the day
restrictions were lifted
in the graph we're showing you march 2nd
is where the red arrow is pointing
and as you can see numbers far greater
than 0
every single day since that day so what
could she even have meant
by by this does uh lauren bobert know
that this is a lie
but she's counting on viewers of this
bizarre show
not knowing that it's a lie not knowing
it obviously doesn't pass the sniff test
and not fact-checking it
does lauren beaubert herself somehow
actually think
nobody died of covet in texas since
march 2nd
the test in 2022 is going to be
does lauren beaubert get re-elected or
does she get removed
from congress this is a really
anti-american person
remember that lauren beaubert back in
december tweeted
save the date january 6
2021 we know how january
6th turned out we know that lauren
beaubert
gave guided tours of the capital
right before the january 6th
insurrection even though the policy at
the time was no guided tours of the
capital
we know that lauren bober tried to use
the recent boulder colorado mass
shooting
to say that we need more guns in more
places which is just the idea she came
in with she'll use anything
to justify more guns in more places um
and this is a a a truly you know the
the right loves to claim uh for
themselves
the privilege or right or
ownership of what is patriotism and what
does it mean to be for
the united states of america but some of
these people
are truly the most anti-american people
that you will meet in terms of
principles
in terms of their perspective on what it
actually means
to abide by the constitution and to
provide people due process
and access to all of the things which
they are entitled to through the
constitution and the bill of rights
this is a disgusting disgusting person
and
if she gets reelected in 2022 if
marjorie taylor green gets reelected in
2022
if madison cawthorne gets reelected in
2022
it will really ingrain that this is the
party of trump
and this is the party that has abandoned
what we're already pretty bad principles
i mean let's be let's be pretty frank
it's not like the republican party was a
great thing under reagan
under mccain romney etc
uh but it was better than what they have
right now and they have a choice to make
now and they will get to make it in what
is it uh 18 months we're 18 months from
the midterm elections
do they say yeah this is what we want
more of lauren beaubert
marjorie taylor green cawthorne the
whole lot of them
or will they say there has to be some
limit to this
i don't know the answer to that but we
will have more on this
and other stories from today's show on
our instagram
find us at david pakman show and while
you're there
follow me on instagram david.pacman i've
been getting some really wacky hate mail
lately
and i posted one of them to my instagram
david.pakman
let me know what you think
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him so i want to keep talking
a little bit about
uh vaccination and about republican
senator rand paul
republican senator rand paul has always
been
sort of an odd guy not the person i'd go
to for
political philosophy or medical advice
or really anything um he has been
obsessed
with badgering dr anthony fauci and
other medical experts with conspiracy
theories
throughout the pandemic dr rand paul
yes is refusing to get vaccinated
against kovid
apparently for no better reason than he
wants to anger liberals
so what do we know about this so far
senator rand paul has now said on a
couple of different shows
he is not going to get a coronavirus
vaccine and
rand has said this multiple times he
said it during an interview with
john katzenmatitis on his radio show
on wabc 770 am
here is rand paul saying it on you know
who knows some other interview that he
did
let's take a listen to it have you
received the vaccine yet now that it's
you know widely available to anybody in
the u.s do you plan to
yeah i had the disease naturally there's
about a hundred million americans who
have had it naturally
all the scientific evidence all of the
studies have shown that there is
a long-lasting immunity from having it
naturally
if people want to get vaccinated if
they're older it's not an unreasonable
thing
but i think for people in my age range
and younger who have had it
i think the vaccine is superfluous but
everybody can make their own decision on
it in a free country everybody gets to
so at this point yes i don't think
there's enough evidence leading me to
think that i need to be vaccinated since
i've already had the disease naturally
now unfortunately there is a lot at
least
probably wrong with what rand paul is
saying
um it's important to mention a lot of
the things rand paul is claiming to know
for sure
are sort of open questions but we have
more and more information that points
actually the other way so there are some
extensive antibody tests that have been
done
and first and foremost it does appear
that the immunity you get from a vaccine
lasts longer than the immunity you get
from recovering from coronavirus
naturally many studies and papers have
found this
we're showing a screenshot of one of
them to our video audience right now
so in other words there's a reason why
people are being told even if you've
recovered from the virus still go ahead
and get yourself vaccinated
uh because it appears as though you know
we we hear about people getting covered
twice
it appears as though the immunity is
longer lasting
and more robust from the vaccine than
from just getting the virus and
recovering now
second again from what we know so far
and much of this is still being studied
but why take a chance
it is less likely it appears less likely
that the variants will get around
vaccine-induced immunity
than natural recovery immunity in other
words
the antibodies that you have from the
vaccine
are more likely to protect you from
variants and this means
all of the major variants of concern the
british variant
of course if you recovered from the
british variant you'll work
you're well protected against the
british variant but big picture
we have the british variant the
brazilian variant the south african
variant california
new york india and there's probably more
at this point in time
it appears as though if you got covered
and recovered naturally
you were less protected against the
variants than if you just just go and
get yourself vaccinated now
this could all be wrong but that's where
things are pointing right now
and so what rand paul is saying very
casually on multiple
interviews and radio and tv programs is
counter to the best medical science that
we have right now
it furthers vaccine skepticism it holds
down
vaccination rates which we're hoping for
i mean listen people who want to get out
of this we're hoping for vaccination
rates to go up
and if people who are already more prone
to be vaccine skeptical because that's
what republicans are right now
if they hear rand paul say this and then
they act on that basis it hurts all of
us
now the bottom line is that this is
merely rand paul i'm talking about
sort of right wing populist type
libertarian tinged
virtue signaling everyone should be free
to do whatever they want it's all framed
as being about liberty and being
about for the people sure
i'm not going to disagree with that but
let's give them real information
remember that tucker carlson on fox news
has been pushing a bunch of really
vaccine
skeptical stuff without saying whether
he
himself is vaccinated we did a segment a
few weeks ago sean hannity on his radio
show
refused to say whether he has been
vaccinated he actually
had some very strange rant where he said
you know i had researched stuff and the
johnson
johnson vaccine was sort of the one that
was most interesting to me
uh but now that everybody's saying get
vaccinated did you get vaccinated
now i don't want to say because of
medical privacy and whatever now it has
nothing to do with hipaa medical privacy
means hipaa
people just casually asking each other
have you been vaccinated which vaccine
did you get did you have side effects
doesn't violate medical privacy doesn't
violate hipaa but sean hannity now
playing coy
something as simple as a historically
effective vaccine
that will save millions of people versus
just letting the virus run rampant
has now become a politicized issue it's
being couched by some of these
republicans
as an issue of liberty and of freedom
when it is really not what it is now for
people who like to say because i know
people will say this
rand paul is a doctor okay listen
rand paul is a medical doctor now some
people will email me some anti-vaxxy
this is so weird
anti-vaxx people will email me and
they'll say you know david
you should really highlight the work of
doctors
who are saying you should not get the
vaccine and then i look and it's okay
it's a phd it's like a doctor of
education it's a
we're talking about medical doctors rand
paul is a medical doctor that is true
he has training as an ophthalmologist an
eye doctor
he hasn't been board certified since
2011
and i love my ophthalmologist i've had
the same one for 30 years
i don't go to him for epidemiological
questions
i don't go to him for questions about
infectious disease
when there are so many experts in the
field including one we interviewed
yesterday dr
isaac bogash from the university of
toronto in toronto hospital
so for anybody who's going to email me
and say but sir
rand paul is a medical doctor okay
save the email i don't need it things
just continue
to get worse and worse and worse
for republican congresswoman marjorie
taylor greene
who now in a resurfaced video resurfaced
by
punchbowl news's jake sherman publicly
stated that she would oppose
the removal of hitler statues
hypothetical ones of course
so that she could tell her children the
importance
of hitler historically my guess
is that there are tons of videos of
marjorie taylor green
saying ridiculous and depraved and
horrible things that will be uncovered
in the future
remember that just in the last few weeks
videos of marjorie taylor green have
resurfaced
in which she shows up to the office of
alexandria ocasio-cortez
and yells things through the mail slot
in aoc's door
at her earlier this week a video of
marjorie taylor green
comparing wearing a mask on the house
floor
to the gassing of jews in the holocaust
was uh
uncovered back in march
marger marjorie taylor green ally uh oh
what was that guy's name i forget the
guy's name an
ally of marjorie taylor green was caught
on video
at the january 6th trump rise i don't
think this is going to stop
here's the latest video marjorie taylor
green
showed up at a dalton dalton georgia
city council meeting
in june of 2020. this was last year
after greene
finished first in the republican primary
but before the general election which
made her a congresswoman and she showed
up and she specifically said
she would fight against the removal of
hitler statues
check this out apparently the context in
general
is that she's against removing any
statues of
civil war figures or whoever else by
liberals naturally
and she says she would even be opposed
to removing statues of hitler
for you all um going into a runoff and
voting for me
i also want to say something else i
think
that this is a time where our nation is
being divided
and we shouldn't be we should be brought
together because
this is the greatest country in the
world and we
like the other man was saying about
breadcrumbs i don't think we should be
fighting about breadcrumbs
i think we should be working to come
together and work
further to keep things good and keep
peace
we're seeing situations where
christopher columbus
george washington abraham lincoln all
kinds of statues are being attacked
and it seems to be just a an effort
to take down history and whether
i see a statue that may be something
that i would fully disagree with like
adolf hitler maybe a statue of satan
himself
i would not want to say take it down
but again it's so that i could tell my
children and teach others
about who these people are what they did
and
and what they may be about so um
as a congressional candidate i just
wanted to come forward and make a
statement
and thank you all for hearing everyone
in your community and also let voters
know where i stand on the matter because
i'm looking to work for everyone here
and i felt like it was important for you
to hear me
so thank you very much even a statue of
adolf hitler
or satan himself she would oppose
removing sort of a strange hill to die
on
i must say and at this point i want to
get back to the hitler statues thing
does anybody else think that marjorie
taylor green
has a sort of strange fixation on nazis
hitler and the holocaust non-existent
mandatory vaccinations
are like the holocaust she says
requiring masks
on the house floor at the house of
representatives
that's like the holocaust a hitler
statue
if someone wanted to remove it she would
fight against that
her reference to jewish jewish space
lasers some months back there's
something odd here
and i don't know exactly what it is now
let's get to the concept of
you don't want to remove a hitler statue
so that you can teach your children
about world war ii imagine teaching
children
about world war ii and the holocaust in
class
showing a documentary film maybe you
invite one of the
increasingly few surviving holocaust
survivors to the class to talk to the
kids
and then you have to do a field trip to
the hitler statue so that the kids can
really learn about it like how does that
even pass the sniff test
how is that even a remotely acceptable
argument this entire
idea that you need a statue
to learn history or that it's even that
useful
in helping people learn history it's a
bizarre idea first of all
who learns history from statues i can
tell you as someone who
i went to school sometimes parents my
parents would talk about history
i would sometimes read books i don't
think i've learned any history from a
statue
it's almost like the write doesn't
realize that documentaries exist history
books exist
teachers exist the internet exists you
can pick up a book
and you can learn something it's that
simple and by the same logic
if she's fine with statues of figures
she support
supposedly uh or apparently hates she
claims to hate
hitler because of the historical
significance
would she be okay with the statue of
like i don't know like a black lives
matter leader or something like if the
statue doesn't mean you endorse it
she should be in favor of it so that we
can learn about it right or something
it's just all completely incoherent as
we've come to expect from her
and the strange she seems to have two
primary fixations
alexandria ocasio-cortez she seems
obsessed with aoc
i don't know if she's obsessed with aoc
because she's jealous of aoc's
uh um sort of coalition and
the attention that aoc gets i don't know
what it is but she's obsessed with aoc
and then between jewish space lasers and
hitler statues and masks are like the
holocaust
she seems obsessed with jewish related
issues as well
let me know what you think we'll have
more about these
strange just video after video
involving marjorie taylor green on our
facebook page which you can find at
facebook.com
slash david pakman show we will take a
break
uh and much more upcoming today
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show
you can check out behind the scenes
pictures
memes shots of the studio shots of
what pat does all day very very
concerning to a lot of people
all of that and more on the david pakman
show instagram account at david pakman
show
we've talked a lot about the i guess i
would call it the need to create
fake scandals and crises kind of out of
thin air
in these early months of the joe biden
administration and part of that is
necessitated by the fact that
while joe biden hasn't done everything i
wish he would he had done and he hasn't
done everything perfectly and
etc etc all the normal disclaimers he's
had
nothing even close to a major scandal
and for a while
and we'll get to this in the in the
voicemail segment um
for a while the focus was on the
so-called crisis at the border
which was not a crisis under donald
trump according to these very same
people
even though nothing really materially
changed from trump to biden
i wouldn't say they've moved on from
that but now the slightly more
conspiratorial
enclaves of the right are going into why
won't joe biden
let us investigate whether kovid was
man-made that's the gist of this and fox
news reporter peter ducey
has gone from asking different foe
gotcha questions
from one press briefing to the next to
just repeating the exact
same conspiratorial pho gotcha questions
day after day so
check this out monday tuesday two press
briefings
exact same question back to back monday
is the first one
peter ducey asked joe biden's white
house press secretary jen
saki about an investigation into whether
covid 19 was man-made now remember
i have no problem investigating that dr
fauci said he has no problem
investigating it
it's just that right now there's no
evidence that covid was man-made but
do the investigation do everything you
need to
in terms of covet 19. so this is monday
here is a peter ducey asking shouldn't
we be investigating this new
investigation but with
589 920 dead
americans at what point does president
biden say
we don't want to wait for the w.h.o we
don't know what they're doing this needs
to be an american-led
effort to get to the bottom of what
happened well first of all we need
access to the underlying data
and information in order to have that
investigation and
why not but he talks all the time about
how he's known president xi
for a long time so why can't he just and
we need them
for that information i think you're
misunderstanding how this process
actually works
an international investigation led by
the world health organization is
something that we've actually been
pressing for
for several months in coordination with
a range of partners around the world
we need that data we need that
information from the chinese government
what we can't do
and what i would caution anyone doing is
leaping ahead of an actual international
process
we don't have enough data and
information to jump to a conclusion at
this point in time
so is there any amount of the
casualties from colbit in this country
that would make you want to
not wait for an international effort and
just do it
as well i i have to say i think the
family members of the
loved ones whose lives have been lost
and deserve
accurate information data not the
jumping to a conclusion without having
the information necessary to conclude
what the origins are
what we do share everyone in this
country as a desire to know
how this started where it started and
prevent it from ever happening again
that's something we all share go ahead
okay so that was monday
and jen saki says yeah do the probe do
it
let's find out peter ducey wants to
frame it and so many of these
wingers you know when they seize on a
kernel of something then they just try
to blow it up into
i don't know popcorn he wants to frame
it as
at what point would covid be serious
enough for joe biden to want to
investigate the origins
of the virus and that's of course not
the issue it's already serious enough
it was trump and republicans who
downplayed the seriousness all along
nobody's trying to block an
investigation into the origins it's just
without evidence right now the assertion
that kovid was
likely or probably man-made is an
assertion without evidence and so we
can't do that
at this point in time it doesn't seem
that he gets it so cut to the next day
yesterday tuesday
peter ducey with the same thing again
and jen saki actually points out
peter didn't we do this yesterday all
right i guess we're doing it again
does president pine think these theories
we hear more about now that kova 19 may
have been man-made and escaped from a
lab in china
are a wacky conspiracy theory or based
on what he has
heard and been briefed on does he think
that's possible well we went through
this journey together
yesterday so let's do it again so the
president believes there needs to be an
independent investigation
one that's run by the international
community it's an international pandemic
that has killed hundreds of thousands of
people around the world
he believes the chinese need to do more
to put forward data to be more
transparent
and in the second phase of this effort
he's certainly hopeful that will be the
case
and he believes that every theory should
be explored through that process but
that we shouldn't jump to conclusions
before
that data and that information is made
available this is straight
up cow towing to the fox news audience
the fox news audience
loves conspiracies they love the idea
that democrats aren't telling them the
truth
and by democrats they also mean
apparently the public health community
now it's also funny to watch the other
reporters
try to creep keep straight faces when
peter ducey is doing this it's hard to
imagine anybody's taking him seriously
in that press briefing room
but they do a good job at pretending
anyway later
just the cherry on top peter ducey also
framing a question about a rise in crime
under joe biden of course the rise in
crime started
last summer under trump much of it
crimes
of economic circumstance as a result of
the pandemic
and good job gensake actually points it
out on the rise
in violent crime i compared to this time
last year homicides
up 113 minneapolis up 38 in philly
up 22 in chicago just to clarify the
white house's position on this is that
that is mostly because of guns well
first i'm not sure what data you're
looking at but i think what we can
most data that is out there shows that
there's actually been a rise in crime
over the course of the last year since
the start of the pandemic which
actually predates president biden taking
office to be totally clear
right now you're right you're right
you're right peter and that's why we're
we are
focused well we're focused on uh
solutions here and that's why we
proposed uh putting a fight we put five
billion dollars in the american jobs
plan
okay so she gets into reading the
statistics which is fine
but just desperate to create chaos and
controversy and it
feels sort of wasted because there
really are good questions that peter
ducey could be asking if he wants to be
tough on the press briefing
uh the the uh press secretary and the
the process of press briefing and taking
it seriously
but instead it's just this drivel time
and time again now i will say one thing
about
jen saki's handling of this her handling
of it is generally good
and sometimes you see like she was
better prepared for that
when you get the same questions every
day you get multiple attempts she was
better prepared
for the covet origins question on
tuesday than she was on monday
but she has to be careful because part
of asking the same
question day in and day out could maybe
be to create an inconsistency where she
says one thing one day and another thing
the next
materially different things or maybe
even a slip up of some kind
which peter ducey and then fox news and
the whole right wing media apparatus
can focus in on in season and make like
a 24-hour story out of it or
even a bigger scandal or pseudo scandal
so
clearly she's tired of it clearly so are
we but she actually does need to stay on
point every time
and take the the fully answer the
question every time that he asks these
questions
even if it's the same question every day
because they're just looking for an
inconsistency from her
gensake apparently the sort of
kindergarten teacher
that's needed in the press briefing room
at this point in time
now let me go br briefly back to the lab
leak or the
the man-made theory of covid um
i i don't know anyone who wouldn't want
to know if kovid were man-made i would
want to know there's no question about
it
the other scenario is if covid were
naturally
occurring but then leaked from a lab
in which it was being studied i would
want to know
i just want the truth but before we have
evidence
it's not responsible to say it's
probably man-made and it's not
responsible to say
that that possibility is being covered
up and that's what the focus is right
now
either the left doesn't want to talk
about it you should see don jr's
recent tweets about this or there's
an actual cover-up of the fact that this
was probably likely
realistically a man-made virus there's
just no evidence of that
study the origins dr fauci said it i've
said it all along
study the origins let's not make
assertions for which we do not have
evidence
this is interesting because it's one of
those stories where
there is not one simple understanding of
the world that tells us what we need to
know
sometimes we need to hold sort of two
ideas that
might appear to conflict simultaneously
and we have a sort of um
bifurcation maybe i would call it
in the united states right now in terms
of the republican party
where on the one hand donald trump is
still clearly the leader of the
republican party until proven otherwise
and yet he is rapidly sliding towards
online irrelevance now you might hear
that and say david sir
how could that be true how could trump
be irrelevant online
but be the revered holy leader of the
republican party
and the answer is something that we
learned through the 2020 democratic
primary which is that the real world
and the online world are two different
things which
remember when bernie sanders appeared to
be dominating
twitter twitter or um reddit
during the 2020 primary and yet joe
biden won the democratic primary in 2020
by quite a bit
we realized what happens online is not
necessarily reflective of what's going
on
in the greater real world so on the one
hand
most republicans still like trump most
republicans want trump involved in
politics most republicans want trump to
run in 2024.
we see this in every poll most
republicans still believe trump did win
2020. most republicans say they would
follow trump to his own
third party if trump were to leave the
republican party most republicans say if
given the opportunity in 2024 they would
vote for donald trump again
but then look at what's happening online
thanks to being banned
from twitter facebook youtube and many
other platforms for his regular
uh rule breaking and incitements to
violence donald trump has been
relegated to his blog at donaldj
trump.com and that blog is having
essentially
zero impact we barely talk about it we
mentioned today
trump's reaction to the grand jury being
convened against them that's big news a
grand jury looking at whether a former
president committed crimes
but it's barely making news what donald
trump writes on his blog
remember that trump and his staff were
regularly
teasing how trump's new online
social media communication platform is
going to
revolutionize everything and put trump
back in the spotlight
it ended up being just a blog that
barely anybody is reading
and as the washington post now reports
online discussions of trump
have plunged to a five-year low in the
last week
trump's website attracted fewer
estimated visitors
than the pet adoption website petfinder
and the recipe website delish so the
incredible sort of fork at which we're
arriving
is that while trump is clearly the
republican party's biggest star
at this point in time and many
republican lawmakers continue to pledge
endless loyalty to him
it is simply not translating to online
influence at all
overall online influence for trump is
down about 95
since january and down to its lowest
level since 2016.
his blog from the desk of donald trump
which they have been
so heavily promoting um sometimes the
blogs are only shared on facebook two
thousand times
we get sometimes two thousand shares or
more of a random video that we publish
to facebook so understand the the scale
of these numbers these
are really low numbers for a former
president
so of course the real question is absent
his ability to make stories viral
is trump going to lose control of the
narrative as we get towards 2022
how does this affect the republican
party in 2022 how does it affect the
republican party and trump in 2024
can trump wield the influence he wants
to wield and be the king maker he wants
to be in 2022
without that bully pulpit i don't know
that he can now in some sense trump may
realize already that he needs to do
something
because we have reports that he's
planning to
i guess get his old the dark blue 757
the boeing 757 airplane
he's planning to get it back into action
for so-called rallies
and for who the rallies will be and
when we we don't really know i do think
that if we close in on 2022
and trump starts doing his fly-in
rallies around the country
in support of republican candidates that
he's deemed to be
acceptable republicans that will get him
attention
because a former president on the
campaign trail gets attention that's
just the reality
but if you doubt at all the reach of
trump's influence today
look at what happened with liz cheney
liz cheney was removed from house
republican leadership by republicans
because she publicly admitted hey guys
trump just lost
he just lost she was with trump 93
of the time on voting it's not like
she's some liberal but she acknowledged
trump lost and she was kicked out of
republican leadership
that simply doesn't happen if donald
trump has lost control of his party
and that is continued proof that donald
trump for now has not lost control of
his party he's losing the bully pulpit
he's lost the majority of his online
influence but he has not lost control of
the republican party at least for now
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p we've talked about the faux
border crisis here is a
right-wing caller very trumpian guy
who uh continues to ask about the faux
border crisis take a listen to this
hi when are you going to cover the
border crisis
thank you listen we've been covering the
facts of the situation at the border
one of those facts is that the biden
administration
they've not handled the border perfectly
there's no they've done nothing really
on immigration that's permanent yet
but the number of migrant children
who are awaiting being reunited with
their families has dropped dramatically
from march to april it dropped
dramatically
the the crisis is a crisis concocted by
public relations
and concocted by republican
communications offices and concocted by
right-wing media that's the simple
reality of the situation
we had a situation at the border and
immigration not dealt with
under the trump administration we have a
situation at the border
and the immigration situation not dealt
with under the biden administration
some improvements have been made under
joe biden but this was their concerted
effort
and the voicemail is proof that it
worked and there's polling that tells us
it worked even though you and i might
remember what was going on at the border
under trump what's going on under biden
and say
it's slightly better but not resolved
right underwhelming but that's the
reality it's slightly better but not
resolved
if you look at polling back in june of
2020
only 28 percent of americans believed
that immigration and the border
were a serious and top issue now
about a month and a half ago 48 percent
of americans
almost doubling believe that the
situation at the border and immigration
is serious and crisis level so
yes they decided hey we need to create a
scandal for joe biden
yes it's a fake scandal but it has
worked and it has convinced
millions of people when something goes
from 28 to 48
in american society that's tens of
millions of people that have been
convinced of something
okay it has worked and you know i don't
know what else this guy wants me to say
we've covered
what's going on at the border and it's
slight improvement from the situation
that trump left us
we have a great bonus show for you today
andrew yang
is going after a tabloid
for what he is calling a racist cartoon
that referred to him as a tourist we're
going to talk about that on the bonus
show today
small business owners in manhattan are
increasingly getting
unbelievably well located uh businesses
as a result of the pandemic we'll talk
about where who why and what the
implications
are and the texas house has voted to
pull
funding from sports teams that do not
play the national anthem
before sporting events which of course
they don't actually
have to do but this is the latest virtue
signal from republicans it's something
that doesn't
really matter it doesn't really do
anything
for the middle class working people
businesses education it's nonsense
it's virtue signaling but it probably
pulls pretty well
with a lot of republican voters and so
that's what the texas house has voted on
we will talk about all of those stories
and more when producer pat joins me on
today's bonus show
get access instantly by signing up at
joinpackman.com
and remember that monday memorial day
now just a few days away
we will be doing a single day membership
bomb
explosion we're going to do a single day
discount off of memberships we're trying
to rebuild
some of the lost memberships over the
last couple of months due to covid
if you want to be notified of that
absolutely
perfect membership special on monday
just get on my
newsletter which you can do so you can
do at davidpakman.com
upper right of the website you type in
your email address you'll be on the
newsletter
and monday you'll be notified of that
special coupon code but for people who
are already signed up
we will see you in near moments on
today's bonus show